there are fascinating questions in this
video for example is gail kneeling to
the statue behind the altar who is his
merciful goddess of the forlorn and what
is the white haired woman's dark soul of
man let's see the painted world has
always been a safe haven in the age of
the gods it was the work of the painter
our yamas hung in Anor Londo and home to
beings like Priscilla whose abilities
the gods feared at some point though we
know that this painting fell for father
re and L restored the painted world and
the cycle of paintings began anew of
course there could have been many
paintings and painters in between these
two worlds of Aramis and re and L
because the residence of this painting
clearly understands that eventually
their world must burn lest their
painting stagnate and rot that's a line
of thought that only really comes about
if they've had generations go through
this and yet re and L decided to eschew
tradition he embraced rot buried the
flame and decided instead to satiate the
flame with his blood and so the next
painter had to be tucked away in the
depths of the painting never to paint
the next world never to see flame tasked
with concealing this secret child of the
painting is Vilhelm loyal Knight of
Frida who is the tyrant of re and oh
I've seen your kind
time and time again every flame must be
cooled every secret must be on earth
such as the conceit of the
self-proclaimed seeker of truth but in
the end you lack the stomach for the
agony that you're brewing upon yourself
Freda was the first ash to enter the
painting yet instead of seeking flame
she embraced the rot along with the good
father and she entrusted Vilhelm
with the key to this library and within
this place are what seemed to be secrets
of the painting as a tyrant as freedom
you want to hide history you want to
hide origins and I think this place this
library is where a lot of that is hidden
perhaps these books hold the histories
of the world
maybe the destroyed statues hide an
important identity and certainly
vilhelm guards the white haired child
who is the key to the future of the next
world
forgive me milady I swore an oath but I
have failed you lady
I've redone the white-haired woman
chairs no name so we call her aria in
keeping with the tradition of painters
named this way I believe I feel the
scent of a ship on me doubt the one of
whom uncle Gayle spoke the one to show
me flame tis good how I docked paint
I promised uncle Gayle I would uncle
Gayle the Japanese text actually
confirms that she doesn't mean uncle in
the literal sense rather she means uncle
in the familiar old man sense this is
important because the parentage of Arya
is something worth going into a bit
later but for now let's tackle gales
curiosities and he has a ton of them
Gayle was once a slave night which was a
warrior used as fodder in the blackest
of battles and perhaps he still is one
be
because that same description mentions
that slave nights were never relieved
from duty
despite their twisted bones and
blackened skin and bizarrely we never
actually get a clue as to what a slave
night's Duty could be nor what entity
they were beholden to for this duty as
its called
additionally slave nights were clearly
downtrodden yet they were given lavish
red armaments its fine craftsmanship a
symbol of Honor so I think all of this
serves to make us feel like Gail is from
a long lost time and one of the oldest
undead in the series and this is a
thought that's reinforced by the miracle
that he alone wields the way of white
Corona is a lost way of white miracle a
white discus which slices through foes
and is so [ __ ] that it's no wonder
people forgot about it long ago when the
imprints left by the gods were still
deep miracles of the way of white
existed alongside Orioles these were the
white disks that existed in Dark Souls 1
at the age of the gods that appeared in
other people's worlds whenever you cast
a miracle the description goes on to say
those who yearned for the long-lost
Orioles fully believed that they would
return one day you find this way of
white miracle in the core vien
settlement in front of their church
altar and this is an altar that looks
stunningly similar to one on the outside
in the Cathedral of the deep which was a
church of the way of white and it's this
same place where Gail the ancient
duty-bound Knight says his next curious
line of dialogue
for goddess mother of the forlorn who
have no place to call their home please
bear witness to our resolve for fire for
area under fire for arendelle
and the ash to Kindle flame so who is
this merciful goddess this mother of the
forlorn whoo Gale still believes is
watching over them perhaps she's the
clue to understanding gales motivations
a list three strong candidates so let me
know which one you think is correct
first kayfa the goddess of tears I came
across this suggestion in the comments
of a missing dialogue video and I love
the theory it drew my attention to the
fact that Gale may well be kneeling to
the figure behind the altar in the
cleansing Chapel which is a statue
that's repeated all throughout the
Cathedral of the deep the woman is
clutching her face almost as if weeping
and this ties in nicely with katha who
is the goddess of Tears and who is
mentioned in the blue and red tears
stone rings as a mourner of loved ones
and of the undeserving dead we don't
know too much about her motivations as a
goddess but we know that she was
famously worshipped by morn and his
archbishop both of whom hail from kareem
and that's pretty much everything we
know but additionally as stellar elite
points out in the comments the cathedral
is a formal way of white church and the
way of white now has a home into Kareem
and Gayle is related to the way of white
so you can see the connections here but
the real question is can she classify as
a merciful goddess as a mother of the
four lon well
followers of kayfa they provide comfort
to the suffering and a goddess of Tears
certainly qualifies her to be a
mouthfull mother of the forlorn don't
you think but the links do stop there
and we've never really had a clue
to kathas motivations and she certainly
doesn't have a relationship with
anything in the painted world so our
second candidate Velka goddess of sin
does have a connection instead of a
claim through the way of white volka
instead is more directly related to the
painted world for example in Dark Souls
1 there was a black pardon a set that
was found within and the crows were
originally envisioned as servants of
velka in the design works though it is
possible that that part of their design
has changed but at any rate Velka
certainly has a relationship with the
sable Church and it makes a degree of
sense for Velka to be invested in the
opposite of what Frieda once since
Frieda was a member of the sable church
who abandoned the church there are also
destroyed female statues that have
loose-fitting robes and one hand out
held which is quite similar to the
Statue of velka in the settlement so
does Velka fit as a merciful goddess as
a mother of the forlorn I think you
could see her that way
absolving sin is a mercy and she has a
statue for just that tucked away in the
undead settlement for absolving sin can
you go so far as to call her a mother of
the forlorn that's more of a stretch but
we really know so little about Elka that
you can't rule it out as for the last
candidate Priscilla she's certainly not
quite classified as a goddess but she's
very much a mother figure and is based
in the first painted world as such she
likely wouldn't tie in with gales Hollow
slave duties but at the very least we
should discuss
Priscilla's relationship with the child
aria most notably arias scaled skin and
her red slitted eyes like Priscilla's
green ones and this court those who
aren't
kenta fire
cannot paint a world those absorbed by
fire must not paint a world don't worry
I haven't forgotten other admittedly
there have certainly been a lot of
paintings between this one and Ariana's
so like so many other things in this
video it's up to you to decide if we can
even guess at Arya's parentage or the
identity of the so-called merciful
goddess mother of the forlorn so what do
you think my thanks ashen one I can
almost see the flame soon uncle Gayle
will bring me the pigment I wonder if he
has found it the dark soul of man the
most curious and tantalizing quote at
the end of the dlc i feel like it's only
fitting that we end the video
in the same way similar to how man can
usurp the first flame arya is also
looking to paint the dark soul of man
upon her canvas as the pigment though
she doesn't have it just yet
gayle is out there searching for it
maybe it's the final piece of his duty
but where does he intend on finding this
what shape does the dark soul of man
take is it as little as a simple
humanity fragment or as large as a soul
of man akin to the soul of cinder as
usual we're left with more questions
than answers and at the end of the dlc
no less and from aren't exactly known
for making sequential DLCs since you can
purchase these separately so I have a
feeling we're going to be left to figure
this out for quite a while to come so
what will the final DLC hold
you